at outward academy in barnsley
42 of the predominantly white children
come from disadvantaged backgrounds
and educators here are unsurprised by
the findings
that the academic performance of white
working-class children
is low compared to poor children from
other ethnicities
i've seen great evidence for example
that newcomer newcomers to the country
the optimism that they come
with can often see education as the root
out of poverty
but for too many communities that were
established they don't see that same
level of importance behind education so
we think it's um
that it's not just poverty it's it's
about geography it's about the jobs the
the the economy in the area
poor white children on free school meals
do badly throughout primary
into secondary school and the impact on
outcomes is dramatic for example
73 percent of chinese pupils on free
school meals
get into higher education with black
african kids from lower incomes it's 59
percent
and black caribbean it's half that at 32
but with white children from the same
low income bracket
it's half again just 16 percent
get into higher education the report
authors conclude
that policies should be directed towards
helping this group
and controversially also say the term
white privilege
shouldn't be used as it contributes to
what they call
systemic neglect of white working-class
children
the concept of white privilege is
entirely
wrong-headed it's wrong-headed because
it implies collective guilt
when it should be in the individuals who
are responsible
for acts of racism you're really saying
to the
single parent who might live in a small
bed sit
in a in a flat in my constituency of
harlow
that she automatically is someone of
white privilege i mean this is why this
has got to be stopped
but others argue that the issues facing
ethnic groups
shouldn't even be a factor in the
question of how to lift
the attainment of white school children
it seems
more like a culture war bomb
than an actual desire to create
betterment within our society for
example white working-class people
are not an ethnic group and throughout
the whole report it refers to white
working class people as an effort group
they are
an economically challenged section of an
ethnic degree which is white people
and one of the problems that we have is
that these debates are always predicated
upon the fallacy
which is white working-class people
versus ethnic minorities
see you tomorrow it all plays into the
politics of race
and left behind communities the
government says it is leveling up
but also that as the largest group white
disadvantaged
children benefit most from schemes such
as the pupil premium
jason farrell sky news